Please help me welcome to the stage.
John [inaudible].
Nitsky Haylie Meyer Shire and released.
Hmm.
Have a seat. Any seat? You black.
Welcome. Any seat except for mine. Okay.
So, uh, reviews came out right
this morning. I, I don't know if
you've read them or if you guys, uh,
don't read them.
No, no. What is that noise making device?
And I mean through reviews were great.
Read one,
which was,
which I guess we'll lead into the
whole talking about the story here,
the unquestionable feelgood movie of 2017.
Have you heard that Pete
Hammond deadline Hollywood? Uh,
congratulations on writing an incredible
story. Thank you. This is Holly.
This is your, your writing debut? Yes.
Directing debut and film debut in general.
Yeah. Yeah, that's my debut. So where,
where did
the, uh, I guess, where did the idea
come from? Where did this originate?
Um, you know, I came from a
bunch of different places.
I had had the character of Alice in my
head for a long time of this woman who
had sort of made a lot of decisions
early in life and then started,
started questioning them.
And that kind of post-separation
post-divorce time in a
woman's life. And, um,
I had a friend who had three guys move
into her family's house growing up and I
just thought that was such an interesting
idea and a great setting for a comedy.
So I sort of put this character in that
sin, in that scenario. And you know,
all came from there.
Huh. Okay. So was there the, in real
life, was there the sexual tension that,
no, I actually don't, I don't
know anything about the,
what actually happened. I,
it is a fictional film.
Sure it is. Yeah. Right.
And recent. John, how did the two of
you get on board the film yourselves?
I read the script, um,
and I just loved it.
I thought it was such an original
idea and um, the idea that, you know,
a decision you make a 25 isn't necessarily
the right decision for the rest of
your life.
And I think a lot of people are crossroads
at certain times and trying to figure
out chapter two of their life.
Um,
and so I met with Holly and she was wildly
impressive and had a great vision for
it.
And we went ahead.
John, what about you? I mean, Sam,
I read the script and was
blown away and you know,
it's about also about three
young filmmakers who uh,
move out to la hoping to make it and may
nat and Pico can all relate obviously
to that. Um, so, you know,
I was honored to be a part of it.
John John came in on my first
day of casting. Yeah, just
very special. Really. Yeah.
And so none of you knew each
other beforehand? No, no, no, no.
I heard.
Yeah. Right. So I guess we Reese you've
been acting since you were 14, 15,
14 and uh,
so with hits gushy,
Pleasantville still one of my all time
favorites from when I was younger.
Cruel intentions, American psycho,
uh, legally blonde, sweet home. Hello.
This is the legally blonde hair.
Sweet. So Alabama walk the line with
what she won the academy award again.
Congratulations.
So
I guess you've been putting out a
movie a year since you were a teenager.
I guess so.
And so you went, you were a child star
and then went to be an adult star.
How did you navigate that complexity
without sort of going a little bit
typically child star?
Crazy.
I mean, I don't know.
I wasn't aware that I,
I wasn't really like a big child starting.
I worked in movies in,
my parents were very adamant that I
stay in high school and then I went to
college so I didn't really start working
with any kind of regularity until I was
about 19 I got a big audition when I was
at Stanford and then I had to drop out
to do the movie and then I got another
movie and I've got another maybe instead
it just started working on, but I thought
it was going to be a doctor. I really,
I'm not the kind of person who would
move to la and live in a car because I
can't, my parents are
about doctor. Yeah. Yeah.
So they did. They want you to be doctors
because my parents were always like,
you can act with computer science degree.
You can't do computer science
with an acting degree,
which is the only advice I really ever
listened to, which landed me here.
So thank you mom. Thank
you mom and dad. Um,
um, yeah, they wanted me to be a doctor.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure they
still want me to be a that.
Did they call you up after they
seem so your movies and like Reese,
we really wish that you had, you
know, become a brain surgeon.
Well I think in the movie is more like
after I do a talk show and I talk about
them a lot, they're like, oh, we wish
she wouldn't talk about us. They're in,
they're against sports.
And there you grew up in the south,
right?
I grew up in Nashville, Tennessee.
My Dad was in the military,
so we were all over the place. How did
you kick the southern accent? Oh, um,
well I got advice when I was about 18.
I went into a casting
office and they said,
you're never going to get work
with that terrible accent. So I,
I watched a lot of TV shows,
like 900 to 100 and I watched the way
that they would articulate and I would
copy them.
Oh Wow. I'm not gonna, I'm
just gonna leave it there.
That's crazy. So your parents burying
a man out of London. What's that?
We're just going through that
and John. Okay. So
dude, SNL. Yeah. People,
people dream about being on
that show.
How did you make the crossover from,
from I guess let's sketch comedy
TV over into this movie business?
Well, um, I wouldn't have gotten the
opportunity to even audition for this,
had it not been for SNL, that
kind of helped, you know,
put me in a room with Halley
and Nancy to begin with,
which was pretty crazy to
even have an opportunity to,
to be considered for
this movie. Um, but, uh,
my background is an acting. I, I, um,
I've been doing theater my whole
life and I studied theater at USC,
so I really have always wanted
to, to act, you know, just,
I just happened to do comedy. In addition
to that, you know, happen to do comedy.
You can, but he's not from the Midwest,
so we're not sure where that,
this looks weird.
Michael Keaton x isn't
cam and he and I know where it's
coming from. I Dunno. I Dunno.
Do I do it all the time or
is it just sometimes, no,
he does lots of different voices.
Yeah. I can't quite tell. Yeah. Yeah,
there's just certain
words that I just like, like I,
I'd like to say about, even though
that's I'm from Jersey,
but like more fun to say about
and I'm going to the buyer,
like I'm going to the buyer. Like why
wouldn't you choose to say it that way?
Just take what you like from
every accident, I guess. Yeah.
Good pack. The cod hovered.
Yeah. Hey, go. Right.
And so highly now turn 30 pre recently.
Yes. I don't know how you hear. No,
that's fine.
I'm good with it.
I bring this up because you make me feel
really insignificant with my own life
decisions. Being older than that. Um,
and having seen now what
you have accomplished? Uh,
I guess it makes me feel like I've had
a few wrong choices when I was 25. Um,
but you started your own acting
career when you were like four. Yeah.
Well,
it's funny I'm being asked a lot,
but I was in no way a child actor.
My parents forced me to be in
their films with basically,
but I'm very grateful because now
it's kind of like I have this personal
connection and a little bit of a
photo album. But no, I was just,
I was always on their sets so
they'd throw me in the movie,
but it wasn't because I wanted to be
an actor. And who are your parents? Um,
Nancy Meyers,
a producer of if our movie and my dad
is trial Shire who was her partner for a
long time. Yeah. And
for those who don't know,
a,
the two of them have produced many
things such as the intern holiday.
It's complicated. Parent trap, Baby Boom,
private Benjamin, a father of the bride.
And if you've heard of any of those
came from this family lineage.
And now apple has not
fallen far from the tree.
This movie is absolutely incredible
and you're standing on your own.
So thank you for continuing this.
Um,
and it is such a fun movie.
Was it as fun to write as I guess?
I guess the question is, was it as fun
too, right as it was for us to watch?
Oh boy,
you got a little over excited Mike Dry and
make the movie writing is, um,
I love writing. That's, yeah,
it's where I identify most
in the filmmaking processes
with writing your, um,
I mean, in my case, I don't
have a writing partner,
so you're completely alone with these
characters and there's so much fun to be
had there,
but it's,
it's it really challenging writing a movie
and layering your character's and uh,
you know,
I,
I think I did probably upwards
of 30 drafts of this script also.
Um, well, I, you know, I did 15 on
my own, then I gave it to my mom,
another field out of that. So, um, is
that scary and giving it to your mom?
Like his hands it back with
a big no because she's the
only person I give it to.
So it's not like I'm
getting a, I just, you know,
I gave it to her and she has such
thoughtful, good notes and just, um,
I think good notes are just
raising the right questions.
She never said you should
do this, you should do that.
It would just say, you know,
why did they break up?
Why did they just raising those questions
that make you go home and think for so
long. Like, Oh my God, why? I don't
know and I don't figure this out. Um,
so I don't even remember the question.
But yeah,
writing is a lot of work and super
rewarding. It was fun. I love,
I love to write. I sort
of, there's this great Joan
Didion quote,
like,
I don't know what I'm thinking until I
write it down and I really identify with
that.
You know,
sometimes you just don't know how you
feel about something until you just write
it down.
[inaudible]
that's interesting. Uh,
yeah. As someone who writes,
because I have to answer emails.
I appreciate someone who
does it.
Yeah.
All right.
I guess where you grew up in the industry,
you grew up around very
successful parents and, and,
and being on sets all the time.
Obviously you have written the maturity
into this film that I wouldn't have
expected from someone, I guess
as young as you are, um, from,
from a certain perspective. So, yeah.
Where did that maturity come from?
Where did your larger view on like,
relationships in life happen?
Um, you know, I think for me, I was,
I was trying a little bit
to honor the medium of film,
which I respect so much and
I wanted to, I, you know,
film is forever and I didn't want to
write about trivial issues. So for me,
the themes of family and divorce
and starting over are important.
So that's kind of why I,
you know,
I think Allison's story and crossroads is,
um,
a little bit weightier and real, or
then the issues of sort of, you know,
you know which guy and you know,
the kind of like 20 something story,
right? Yeah. And that I
enjoy in this, that did,
it doesn't take the normal like slap
stick kind of silly turns that that Rom
coms, romantic comedies do
in most cases. So it was,
it was a pleasant surprise and I think
that's why of course today the reviews
are coming out and they're
all very positive. So, uh,
you've done a good job there.
Um, regarding the characters, I
guess. So we saw in the preview,
there's lots of other people in it.
Obviously it's not just the three of
these people. Here are the two of them,
then a director. Um, Michael Sheen is the,
is is a house as husband Candice
Bergen is Alice's mom. Uh,
we've got lake bell's
a wonderful addition.
How did all of these wonderful people
come give you get attached to this first
time directors film?
Um, well, you know,
the casting is such an important
part of the process because you're,
you're sort of handing your character
off to somebody and letting them make it
their own. So it's, it's um, it's
such an important thing and we,
we thought really deeply
about this and um,
it was a really nice mix I think of
newcomers and seasoned actors and I think
that mix added something
fresh to the equation.
It really felt like there was different
generations in this movie. And um,
I have to say, you know, we,
we sent it to these people and sometimes
you think you'll never hear back or
what.
And the,
a lot of them responded and my mom
had worked with like bell before,
so we knew her,
but the rest of the actors in this movie
or just good old fashioned sending them
the screen
then hoping they'll say,
yes.
You have to realize as an actor you don't
get a lot of scripts where you get to
play a character anymore. Like it
is. Yeah, it's pretty rare. And,
and to have a fully fleshed out character
with a beginning and a middle and an
end or a real journey or real lines to
say or humor is really an anomaly these
days. I mean you're honestly just
reacting to a green screen and, okay.
Ah,
does it hurt here?
Like what am I on?
Said I'm not sure we're
going to put it in language.
Just give me like six different reaction.
Do it
hers are starving and do something
really meaningful and deep.
Hmm. I, I guess I didn't realize that the
bad guy with the green screen was never
preconceived beforehand.
Sometimes they just,
they have no idea what's coming next.
It's a working, working with
the w, the three stooges. Um,
was there any parallel there by
the way? No. No. Why three guys?
I'm sidetracking here. Why three
guys? Why not one? Why not two?
Uh,
I think good things come in threes.
It just was always going to be
a trio for me. I don't know.
Fair. Okay. So back to my original
thought. It was always three.
So this is a little bit of a spoiler.
Um, some of you have seen the movie,
we screened it here last night.
Uh, so at the end I was actually,
I was pleasantly surprised to
find that the end of the story,
Alice doesn't choose any
of the men, um, which is,
which is cool.
Great.
They just das
imagine that,
don't need a man to be happy.
Uh, it, it's refreshing to see a romantic
comedy where like the fee the female
protagonist finds happiness
on her own. Sure. John,
I choose here.
Yeah,
I did. I did think that you
were going to go for John.
That was going to say that to me
too. Yeah. I'm writing a sequel.
Okay.
Home again.
Still home again. Um, yeah,
I guess that's what that is one of the
most powerful things about this movie
that I feel every woman is
portrayed as a strong woman.
Even like the smaller
supporting characters are,
they're all, none of them are,
are typically like you're frail,
weak sort of women, you know,
they're often portrayed.
Uh,
was this a conscious choice when you were
writing it and I guess for you Reese,
was this something you noticed in the
script that attracted you to the role?
Yeah, I don't, I don't, I mean,
I don't play a lot of weak.
Amen.
I don't really know any week.
Say if you want to be a woman,
you better be tough.
And that's the only kind of women I know.
So that's, that's, yeah. Hell he writes.
Yeah, I wouldn't have, I don't know.
I also don't know any Greek
women who wouldn't have gotten,
it wouldn't have come naturally to
me to right. That she's vulnerable.
[inaudible] that's for sure.
And she gains strength by the end of the
film and self confidence and feeling,
you know, like she's going to be okay by
the end. But no, I don't, I don't know.
Never. I wasn't consciously
thinking this is a strong woman.
I just thought this is a woman.
And
so you've also, yeah, I
agree. Very well written.
And so Erica Oldie,
oldie produce this as well. So she's
only just only been producing for,
you know, just a few years
too. She's a new producer. Um,
and I was reading up on her too,
and she produced this film.
It's primarily made by women as well.
So how did,
how did you find her?
How did she become attached?
Um, after I had written the
script, do you know, we, uh,
gave it to our agents who wanted to help
us get the financing for this movie.
And Erica was the right person,
I think because she,
her whole company is based around
women's stories and I think she has a
particular affiliate, like she
loves these kinds of movies and um,
she wanted to tell women's
stories and help female directors.
So it was a really nice pairing and
she's a young woman herself. And, um,
I was great.
Yeah.
That's wonderful. And so
Reese, a little side question,
I guess over the last few years,
um, so you'd be getting in,
producing yourself and your
produce big little lies, which
donations for that,
which is wonderful. Um,
what made you want to get into producing?
Um, well, about five years ago,
I read probably the worst script
of her ride my entire life. And,
uh,
the part for a woman was just
absolutely dreadful opposite of guy.
And I called my agent and I said,
well, let's just a piece of crap.
And I don't want to do this.
And she said,
every actress in
Hollywood wants this park.
And I thought we deserved
better than these parts.
And so I was like, I better, I can
either start complaining about it,
which isn't gonna do any good
or I can do something about it.
So I started buying books and turning
them into movies in my first two were wild
and gone girl.
And um,
and so I just started from there and
creating parts for other women as well.
And that's sort of been the
next chapter of my life.
So do you enjoy performing still more
or are you aiming more towards the
producer side?
No, I like being an
actor. I really love it.
It's my first love it and I get
on set and I get all excited.
She's so good at it, I enjoy it. But
I love pretty saying and
I'm really a big reader,
so I read a ton and um,
and then I can just,
and I kind of have an eye for what
is actually going to get made.
And what's cinematic because
not every book is, you know,
things can be beautifully written but
just it's not going to happen. And, um,
I think those two things together really
help create a successful producing
career.
You should produce a movie you star in
where you play a doctor and it would
satisfy everything I said. Yes.
A brain surgeon. Thanks mom.
Uh, going back, I guess to the casting,
you have two wonderful
children that you cast,
Lola Flannery and Eden Grace
Redfield. Yeah. Was it,
is it harder to find a,
to cast roles for children or to cast
roles for adults and specifically for
these two kids?
How did you,
yeah, it's really hard to catch
children because um, you know,
their parents rehearse it with
them. So there's, it's hard.
Sometimes when I was watching
the auditions it would be
like they've had a very
specific way of saying it in a specific
rhythm and you feel like you might have
to undo that a lot,
but these two kids and that you could
just feel that there was something
supernatural,
not supernatural,
but very natural about them.
Um,
there was sort of,
well the little one caught my eye honestly
because she was racist twin and we
were like, this is a little Reese.
And then she happened to be,
to have this fantastic comedic timing
and be, you know, super unique and um,
Lola,
you know,
I really wanted somebody in that part
that could play the comedy of being
anxious, but you wouldn't
actually be super worried for her.
You just felt like this was a
stage she was going to come out of.
And I think Lola has kind of an
inner happiness to her that are very,
she's very sweet and then the
sweetness comes through and um,
I think they just both were so
natural, you know, they really,
they didn't feel like child
actory they just, you know. Yeah.
And John, I guess your
character, uh, you guys, you,
you and Lola have great onscreen chemistry
where you liked that offset or off
camera too? Yeah, we really hit it off.
We were, uh, we would sing a Dell alive.
We were tight. We all got along.
It was really one big family, uh,
almost instantaneously I would say.
Cause the guys actually
ended up living together
together. Yeah. You know, I didn't,
when they got cast that we all live
together like now was a bad idea,
but it turned out all right. Turned down.
I can, I can still speaking now. Wait,
well yeah, a little bit more jacket
and we are, we are one busy working,
uh, around the globe.
Still owes you some rent.
But now when we all talk we all love
each other a great deal. And then, yeah,
I guess you touched on
family, I guess that uh, uh,
the whole cast does to
me seem like a family.
Like we're watching this family
literally and figuratively on screen. Um,
when did,
when was the first time that everybody
sat down together that everybody met as a,
was there one point when
everybody got together to
can also rehearsal?
Yeah.
Yeah. Everyone. Yeah, we sort of,
there's a lot of intertwined
relationships in this movie.
So we did a lot of rehearsals,
you know, with the different, um,
like John and Lola and then John and
Reese. And the reason that, you know,
it's like everyone has a different
relationship in this movie. So we, um,
we all got together and talked
about those different dynamics.
I think that's when it first
started. Jelling yeah. Yeah.
When did you realize that you had
something really special that was kind of
bubbling up here?
Um, that's a good question. You know,
I think there was a really great energy
on the set. It didn't, it didn't feel,
I felt like we were making a feel good.
I thought when we were making the movie,
you know, it had a nice energy and um,
you know, my mom was the producer,
which added another family element.
It really literally was
a family. Um, recess.
Kids would come by and John's parents and,
you know,
it was fun.
Why is that?
Work on my lines.
Yeah.
The tone of the movie really match the
tone on set, honestly. Yeah, I really did.
Oh, that's, that's incredible. Um,
I guess I would have loved a
bit of fly in the room, I guess.
Did you don't do a table read or
anything for the movies to you?
I think for this head, you, Tamari,
y'all and y'all came in and was
somebody who was auditioning. Again,
I read this with all my friends. No, not,
I did a table reading at his house with
actor friends. Yeah. That's amazing.
Why didn't you invite any of us?
Well,
we all just debated about this word that
none of us could say. And we were like,
what was the word? He
was like c h. A I. S. E.
I was like, oh shit. And
then John was like, shoes.
Yeah.
What do you call it? I shake machine.
That was one of the bank to me.
So every time there was in the room,
they'd be like,
there's the
had to be it Shay's because
you sleep on it that night.
And that's why I said chat. So you
couldn't sleep on a chair that night.
So it has that is that, I know
today we'd call it a self. The bad
hello.
So for medicine is different.
I don't know.
Not a shoes
or John is wrong.
That's little I know about.
Yeah, she's doesn't have a pullout.
That's, I guess that's the difference.
You're fancy. It's got the little
swoopy arm thing, doesn't it?
Oh yeah. Am I wrong? It can. It
can have a swoopy arm. All right.
Well my shit smartest minds in the world.
Okay.
And they have randomly Google it.
I guess you're in trouble here though.
Yeah.
Nobody's banging it.
Not a single person brings it.
What? Q and a are they doing right? Yeah.
They're not
the clown from it.
Yes.
A
balloon.
A bunch of scared kids.
Hi Kelly.
I'm just, I'm that no one's picturing
somebody on a stage over there with a,
the little face drawn on scary.
Oh Gosh. Okay. So the whole,
the whole movie takes place in La.
Um, where did you actually film this?
Was it actually in la?
Yes, it was actually in
La on the west side of La.
And what, whose house was a
lovely gentleman named bill.
Um, it used to be Cindy
Crawford's house. Yeah.
It kind of has a Hollywood history
for gardeners before that. Okay.
Yeah, I found the house. Um,
I googled that Spanish houses on the
west side of Los Angeles because I knew
that's where we wanted to shoot the movie.
And I found it on a real estate listing
and we left a note in your mailbox.
Wow. Crazy. That stuff doesn't happen.
Yeah. I mean I was watching
like that. I'm very lucky.
Wow. Am I mean, I guess talking
back to the family lineage,
like everything your parents did to
had it was set in these massive just
beautiful houses. Is that yeah. They
got to build there. Is it really?
Yeah. Back in the heyday of the romantic
comedy. Wow. And they build their set.
So, um, you know,
which is the nice thing about building
your sets is when you write a scene and
you say,
you know,
she enters this way and he enters this
way and then you can build that and it,
it tells your story through the sets.
Um,
but what was amazing about this house was
I had storyboarded the whole movie and
I was so nervous to find a
location cause I, you know,
you write things that he fixes this and
this and they look through that window.
So I was like, I'm going to have to find
a house full of windows because so many,
it's kind of a visual Motif and the movie
is people are looking through windows
and seeing things happening and then
it got to this house and it was,
the windows were all in the right
places. I was like, this is it.
I had a guest house to and an had a guest
house, which was great. That's crazy.
Yeah.
And so was it empty?
Did you stage it or was anything
like original? This guy bill,
you said any bells,
furniture and make it into the movie?
No.
So we sold
some of Jennifer Garner's curtains.
Yeah,
the movie.
Thanks Jen.
Does she get a credit and thanks to
Jennifer Gardner for providing curtain for
having good days?
Yeah, I guess so. I guess, uh,
what happens to the PR?
The bill wasn't living there.
What happens to the person
when you're displacing them?
For how long did it take to shoot this?
No, he didn't. He didn't
live there, live there? No,
he was about to renovate it and I think
we got to him right before, right before.
Yeah. I was very lucky that he didn't
live. That's also an unusual thing.
Usually you have to put that person up
and when you inconvenienced them in such
a way, but he didn't actually live
there. I don't know. Something was right.
It was some, something in the stars
were aligning for their special.
Oh, super natural. This is
what it was. Cause it was the
kids. The kids grow pecans.
Yeah. How long did it, 30 days.
I think you shut the whole thing in
a month. Less than, yeah. Wow. Yeah.
That's crazy.
Nope.
Okay.
All right.
How do you long do you think it takes to
make a movie? I don't know. Green screen.
This stuff takes like eight months.
Right.
Actually, when we wrapped, my
mom was like, I mean I usually,
this is like, I have five
more months. This, you know,
it was amazing that I think everybody
really, a lot of movies. Yeah. 90 days.
What else? 30 35 almost every
movie my entire career. Wow. I,
I don't have like monsters.
Blasters.
Hey Leah, you could actually
just shoot people writing.
Yeah.
It usually takes about 30 to 40 days
and with rehearsal and everything
too. Yeah. Wow. That's incredible.
I didn't know know that there's
some new thank you audience.
If you guys have questions,
there's two mics in the aisles and you
can begin to line up here and ask anybody
anything, whatever you would like to. Um,
Oh yes. So we've got one
already. All right. Hi.
Hi Guys. Thanks for coming. Um,
before I ask my question, John,
I actually saw your mom
before standup comedy
at the comics. Wow. Okay.
Yeah, she told us a story about how
she liked, messed up your camp clothes.
This is crazy.
It's amazing.
Do you want me to comment on that?
Yeah. My Mom, first of all, my mom
is 57 and just started doing standup.
Great.
That's pretty cool.
She's going to freak when she finds
out that you're asking this and yeah,
my mom tells a story about, uh,
when I went to sleep away camp,
um, my parents are divorced
and my dad's very Thai Bay.
My mom's a total
mess and my dad called her is like,
you put John's name and all the clubs,
right.
It labeled his name on all
the clubs. My mom was like,
Oh yes, of course. Of course.
And she like immediately hired
somebody but the labels on.
But when they were all done,
it said my name on the front.
Okay.
So it's like down my zipper
and I crossed my hands. Yeah.
My Mom's whole joke is when I got
back I was crying and I said, uh,
it didn't make any friends,
but everybody knew
my name.
Yeah.
My question is for East
[inaudible].
That's great.
A really big reader.
In fact,
Pacific Standard's last movies had been
like my favorite books from last five
years. So it's been really
exciting. Um, but my question is,
so how do you know kind of,
I'm a very big believer that the books
are always better than the movies,
but it's been really enjoyable to watch
all of my favorite books in the last
couple of years been these
amazing movies and shows.
So how do you know kind of when you're
reading something that this is going to
translate really well to the screen?
That's a really good question.
Um,
it's a little complicated I think because
of knowing what people will actually
buy and turn it into a movie and it's
two sisters during the French Revolution.
It's just not going to be a
movie. It's too expensive. Um,
it's too niche. So I think I try
to find things that are universal,
kind of relatable and um,
and my main directive has just been
have a woman at the center of it doing
something, sort of telling another
aspect of um, the female experience.
So gone girl is like, I don't know
what she psychotic, I don't know.
But it's something that took a,
an idea of the perfect girl and kind
of flipped it on its head and wild.
I'd love the idea of a woman versus
nature cause you see men versus nature all
the time.
Right.
And then I'd never really thought about
what's the movie where women are up
against the environment by themselves.
Um, so it's just stuff like that.
Things that feel fresh and new.
Cool. Over here. Hi.
Um, so you talked about,
um, the availability of
roles for men and women, um,
over your 20 years, uh, in the industry.
How have you seen that evolve in,
do you feel like we're at a point in
time where there's a lot of momentum for
roles for women?
Or how does that work?
Yeah, I mean, I think it's
a better time than ever. Um,
but I have to say when I started, it
was a good time for women's movies. Um,
women were the stars of their own movies
at the time I came up. I was, you know,
I was lucky I got in a window where I
made legally and sweet home Alabama. And,
um,
I can be the lead of a movie.
I think it's harder now
and particularly in movies,
you don't see women being the
star of movies very often. Um,
I've heard people say
it straight to my face.
We have one movie movie that has
a woman starring in it this year.
We don't need another one. Um, so,
but the great news is with all these
streaming services and the, um,
the new platforms, there's now
they need content more than ever,
and that creates opportunity for women
of all ages, women of all color, um,
people. So it's really kind of
broadening the spectrum and,
and creating more roles.
Thank you. Yeah. Yeah.
Um,
I want to thank you guys for being here.
I want to hell you mentioned earlier
that you felt like you were making a feel
good movie and I feel like we all
need that right now, so thank you.
Um, and then I just wanted to say, um,
I was thinking yesterday while
I was watching movie, you know,
you're one of my favorite actresses.
What would I say if you're actually
here and actually at Google, um,
and I was thinking about how you've had
this history of performing in election,
in curl intentions,
all of these women who are not too strong
but sort of strong in ways that people
don't want them to be or
don't quite understand,
and that they're successful in ways
that don't fit with expectations.
And I think that's sort of
a really interesting message
for the women in Google
right now.
Many of whom are enrolls that people
don't expect them to be in our don't quite
trust them to be successful in.
And it's your particular
history of performances.
An interesting one right now.
And I'm not shocked to see this many
women here in this room and screaming for
Aarp legally blonde, crazy flick, although
she was left out of your recitation. Um,
so just want to thank you
for that. And also, Hi John.
Yeah.
Hi.
Um,
I feel like I have so many questions to
ask race cause I feel like it would be
best friends
if we ever left. Really. I
think we probably would. Yeah.
But you actually said something that
changed my whole life question dynamic
before.
Um,
you said there was a script that you
read that was like really crappy for the
woman. Did that ever
get made? Yup, sure did.
An Oscar winning actress.
Really?
Are you able to say I
didn't do well or that dot?
No, it did not terrible. Maybe, you know,
I've always had a thing where,
and back to your point about being a
woman who does sort of unorthodox things,
I turned down so many parts were like I
got a lot of opportunity after legally
blind to play the girlfriend and superhero
movies, girlfriend, girlfriend, I,
I was like, why would it be a
girlfriend when I give me the lead?
I would rather take less money be the
lead of a movie show girl that she can be
the center of her own story than be a
very wealthy girlfriend and you know,
cause it doesn't move the needle for me
and a certain point, it's all about it.
I also have a little,
I had a little girl when I was 23 so it
kind of shifted my perspective of like,
what do I want her to see on film?
I grew up with Holly hunter and Debra
winger and Diane Keaton and Meg Ryan and
those were events for me when they had
movies coming out on a Friday night.
Like that's what I wanted to see
a woman who's figuring it out.
Like she doesn't know what the next step
of her life is going to be and I just
think that's what drives me every day.
It's why I have a mission,
just to create those parts for myself,
for other women,
for female directors to have that
opportunity to tell women's perspectives.
Because if we don't see women's
perspectives, I mean we've,
we've talked about this, women and
women's films treat men differently.
The men treat the women differently.
That's a narrative that's important.
And I would say the same
thing about women of color,
women of different
generations, you know, all,
all different perspectives need to
be represented and it's just enough.
I've had enough of the same people
telling the same dang stories.
Like if we don't,
if we don't see some new perspectives,
society can't change and we can't
have different conversations.
And that's how I feel about it.
[inaudible]
hi guys,
my name is Brooke Taylor,
which is actually a
character in legally blonde.
It's made me super popular in fifth grade.
A question I got asked on my first day
at Google is if I could have lunch with
anyone dead or alive, who would it dead
or alive? Who would it be? And I said, oh,
what's that made me even more
popular. So thank you. Um,
thank you very much for
the glamour article.
I'm sure that's been
circulating quite a bit. Um,
you have a lot of ambitious
women in the room who are strong,
not because they're strong women,
but because we're women
and that's what women are.
Can you speak a little bit to the article
and just give us some advice and um,
even talk about how it's been received,
if you've gotten any sort of feedback.
Yeah. Well, thank you so much for saying
that. I worked really hard on that.
I recall I probably did 30 drafts.
Um,
because I do think it's really
important what she say. But I,
for probably like three years ago I was
asked to give a speech at this glamour
vet about ambition and women and why
that's considered a negative trait and
women,
and they did this study at Columbia that
identified it as a negative trait in a
coworker, as a female coworker that
she seen as selfish or self serving.
And I thought why has that become such a
negative thing? I was always ambitious.
Even as a little girl, I didn't know
you were supposed to hide it. Right.
So there's this new Harvard study that
women who are seen as ambitious hide it
if they're single. And I, I really,
that just drove me up a wall
cause I thought I run away
from anybody who doesn't
like your ambition a guy or a partner
because it should be encouraged. I mean,
and it's not a self serving thing.
It's like most women who are
ambitious have a bigger goal,
were community leaders where
we're strong family leaders,
we can change a lot and
and create a lot of change,
but we're stymied because of this
stigma around being ambitious.
I think it's why a lot of women don't
run for office. As we look at women go,
of course she wants to win,
why shouldn't she went?
She's probably going to help us, you
know? And I think we have to change it.
We have started talking about it and I
have had a lot of response from men at
big companies who wrote me and said,
I never thought about it that way.
And I've heard women talked about
in board rooms and stuff is boy,
she's climbing and she, and he goes, I'm
going to change the conversation. And I,
I just, Oh yeah, they're talking,
you're talking about your daughters,
you're talking about your sisters.
You know,
we need women were 50% of the population.
We're 50% of the change. Yeah.
You know? Amen. Sister
[inaudible]
my question is also for Reese,
it's about big little lies. Okay.
I'm actually born and raised in
Monterey, California. I'm like, God,
I know it's rare.
And I wanted to ask you about the decision
to change the setting of that book to
Monterey because it feels really
important to the story. So why Monterey?
Um,
why like that story in particular?
Oh, that's, that's a good question. And
because it's set in a Sydney, Australia,
the writer said it there and we
decided to Americanize it, um,
because I want it to be in it.
[inaudible]
so is there sat and I do a
terrible Australian accent and um,
and then Monterey,
because we wanted it to be in a coastal
town that wasn't Los Angeles because
that has its own identity.
The writer was, um,
David Kelly is from that area and lived
in that area. And, um, the directors,
Jamar Valet wanted to use water
as a metaphor for the dark,
mysterious unknown that lies inside of us,
the secrets that lie underneath the calm.
And he did,
I don't know if y'all have seen it,
but the last episode is you see why
he's always filming the ocean. And, um,
so yeah, it's a metaphor. Yeah. Cool.
Hey guys, thank you for
being here. I'm Katie.
So my question is a little
interactive in nature.
It's directed towards you,
but I would love it if you could
maybe use John as your student.
Yeah,
so as I'm sure you guys have heard as
well as a lot of us in this room have
experienced dating in New York is
notoriously pretty tough. Gosh,
a
girl,
a girl
or a guy could use all the
help that we could get.
So I was wondering if you'd be able to
give us all a refresher on the bend and
snap.
I do the, it's Santa as you.
Okay. You want me to teach?
Yeah. Well first you have to
know why you're doing. Sure.
You're trying to get someone's attention,
right? Motivation. Okay. Right.
So you pretend that you
dropped something on the ground
and then you lean forward
and then you snap.
Well done.
Pause.
Oh my God.
I follow that question.
Talked a lot about the importance
of having really powerful,
strong female characters are presented
in the narratives we tell on screen.
But there's so much work that goes in,
whether that's on the part of producers
or writers or a cameraman on the
backside of things to make those
characters appear on screen.
What advice do you have for,
there are lots of creatives that are at
Google who outside of our nine to five
are like myself,
are screenwriters or work on the
production side or the editing side.
What advice do you have for trying to
get your material in front of the right
eyes in an industry where there
are so many barriers to entry,
especially for women,
right?
Do you want to attack to take that?
Um, well, I mean, in my opinion,
the best way to get your
content out there as a,
to have a very original voice and to not
be afraid to tell your specific story
because then it feels very you. Um, and I
think like Reese mentioned, it's such a,
it's a really good time
to be a content creator,
I think because there's so many
platforms. Um, so, you know,
I think just not being afraid
to cold email people, send
your material out there.
I mean, I know it's idealistic, but I,
I am a big believer in good material
gets found and gets recognized, you know,
and, and like Reese mentioned, there's
not a lot of strong roles for women.
And so if you are,
I hope writing those kinds of characters,
I think it will be
recognized and you know,
from youtube to Amazon to
Netflix, I think, you know,
all of these places have their
own content now and will not,
I don't know if we're at wa or Google,
you know,
wherever you want it to
send your material too.
Yeah. Youtube. Yeah. Yeah. Um, so I
mean that's, that would be my advice.
And just start making stuff.
Don't, don't get stuck cane out.
Even if you make a short with your
friends or you get everybody together on a
weekend and make a short film a year,
you're getting stat,
actual film and experience
under your belt. And, um,
there's so many places,
like New York Film Festival has a
new program for female directors.
Warner Brothers is doing a pilot program
for female screenwriters that want to
be directors that you read a 10
minute short and submit it. Um,
there's a lot of those kinds
of things and um, yeah,
you just start making but
don't get stuck or over.
Um,
I don't know.
I just see a lot of creative people get
stuck and it's good sometimes to work in
a group too because it pushes you
out the door and you have a partner.
Yeah. Yeah. And um, when
I was first starting out,
youtube was how I,
that's how I got my agent was from making
sketches with buddies, you know? Yeah.
That's great. Yeah. Let
me think. It is, I mean,
even though the statistics are terrible
about being a female director, um,
I do think because of
people like Lena Dunham,
people think that young women
might be great at what they do.
And I think she's paved the way
for a lot of young women too,
for people to recognize. I do think
it is in some ways a good time to be,
you know, a female content
creator. Great. Thank you.
Cool.
I look down and look up and there's 5
million people asking questions again. Uh,
yeah. Molly. Hey. Hi.
Um, hi. I'm Molly. I'm super excited that
you're here. All of you. Thank you. Um,
so my question is for Reese, but
I think you can, Haley, I'm Don.
You can both answer it. Rick, you've
done so many different movies,
different genres, production company,
draper, James. Um, what's next?
What is one thing you'd love to do? And
John and Hailey, what's next for you?
What's your next big projects?
I'm thinking we would like
to do outside the box.
Um,
well I just extended my production coming
in to digital and mobile programming,
so I'm going to be capable of making more
short form content because I do think
that's the first step to finding new
female voices. That's great. Yeah.
I mean, I'm going to, I don't know if
I'm doing anything outside the box.
I'm definitely going to keep trying to
do what I did here and make you know,
comedies.
Um,
which seem to be fewer and further between
now and put women at the forefront of
them. So yeah, more of the same.
Um, I'm working on a show
with my writing partner with,
for comedy central at the moment.
And then I'd like to, you know,
like to do more good movies,
man. Keep working. I'll be nice.
And this is my first really. So our
first. Yup. Yup. Thank you. Yeah.
Cool. All and we have time
for a few more questions.
Hi. Thank you all for being here. Um,
so today there was an article in the New
York Times about rotten tomatoes. Um,
basically there's a bunch of people in
Hollywood who are planning like putting
blame on rotten tomatoes for
movies, not doing well. Um,
basically saying when these reviews
come out and they get like an aggregated
score that kind of like predicts movies
not doing well at the box office. If,
you know,
the critics are saying it's bad and
it's surfaced on different sites like
Fandango or even when you
search iMovie on Google,
which is relevant to all of us here.
So I'm curious what you think about that.
If that really is
something that's relevant,
if that's something we can lay blame for.
I know about blame. I mean I think rotten
tomatoes is owned by Fandango, I think.
Yeah. So you know, it's one in
the same. Um, I, you know, for me,
I think it's a part of the equation, but
I don't think the actual audience, um,
cares that much about it. And I
think rotten tomatoes is largely men.
So we made a movie about a woman and uh,
so I don't know that they're
necessarily, I don't know. For me,
I wouldn't look at it. I, but I
wouldn't judge a film by it, but I,
I'm am aware that, you know, it is a
big part of things. I think, I mean,
correct me if I'm wrong, but I think
more men look at the scores too.
Like my boyfriend would say,
well, that huddle and I'd be like,
care if game of fine art.
Yeah.
I think it does have an
effect in certain capacities.
If there's something people really
want to say, they're going to see it,
but I think it can drive a movie that
might be on a bubble for two people
waiting to later. And you know,
certain movies like this, like we are,
we're coming on the box office. We need
people to show up and see the movie.
And if you want more movies
with women at the center,
you have to shop and buy the tickets.
Or it's just, it's hard. It's,
you know, it's data that the
studios look at and they think, oh,
well that one didn't do good in this wind
in it. So they don't make more of them.
Um, it's just a numbers
game. But I will say we need,
Ann Patchett wrote this
amazing essay about like,
don't let other people make your
judgments for you. You know, don't,
don't you have your own opinions
about art and books and music.
I hate, oh, I might, I'm
fortunate on son. He'll be like,
well, I heard it's not good.
And I'm like, yeah, but
who did you hear it from?
And maybe you guys don't have the same
taste and maybe you're not interested in
the same thing. So I really encourage
people out there form your own opinions,
have something to talk
about, you know, see movies.
I loved seeing movies and
having a different opinion
than other people because
that's what makes you you.
Um,
and we've taken that out a little bit
by reading too many reviews or listening
to too many people's opinions
on Twitter and stuff.
I think makes probably two more questions.
Yeah.
Hi, I'm Chloe. Um,
so we'll just talk about like this
quote unquote strong female character.
It got me thinking. Um, this
is a question mostly for Reese,
but I would love to hear how these
thoughts too, if you have any. Um,
obviously I love legally blonde,
but one of my favorite movies of yours
actually is freeway. Um, and it got to be,
you know, I was thinking about
the, how a lot of people, um,
see women in action movies and how
just a woman like punching someone or
shooting someone can be like just enough
for people to give them the strong
female character label. But,
um, obviously there's like,
you've been doing so many romcoms and
comedies and like big little lies.
And I was wondering what you think of
the difference in value of a strong woman
in a comedy versus like a family drama
versus an action movie like freeway or
like some more recent ones
like Mad Max and atomic blonde.
Yeah,
I mean all of those genres are great
and I think more than like looking for
strong or weak.
And look,
I answered that question because I
think of myself as a strong person,
but like I'm just looking for complexity
because women just aren't good bad.
There's this whole rainbow of
other things in between, you know,
they're complex and confused and I'm
contemplating things and some of them are
just plain strange,
all know,
like I want to see every color of the
rainbow. I don't want to just see like,
I dunno.
Sometimes I think you just get watered
down and it gets watered down because
they don't understand the complexity of
the female brain because you're not a
woman writing it. So, um, yeah.
What do you think? I don't know.
I mean, I don't see a ton of action
movies. It just not, you know,
as an audience member,
my favorite John Rhe um,
but I do think sometimes the women in
those movies are considered strong because
they're acting like men.
Um, and you know, for me,
the characters that have meant most to me,
the ones that resist portrayed are strong
because they're complex and they're
real, you know, there's something
real about them. I don't,
I don't think you see a woman in an
action movie and think that's me. Yeah.
Just like her and atomic blonde.
Um,
even though it can be super entertaining
and great to watch, you know,
for me it's the relatability of a
character that is that, you know,
if you see Reese on screen being strong
and she's going through separation,
that might give you, you know,
if I can do it too, you know,
and I think that's for me where
the strength comes from onscreen.
Thanks John. You have a favorite
genre, favorite genre, genre, you know,
the right answer really.
I, I'm not really into, uh,
like superhero action movies.
I do like smaller stories
typically. Yeah. Interesting.
But it drama or comedy and done.
I just finished Ozark.
I thought that was real good.
Really good. Yeah. Yeah. I'm like,
that's cool. Yeah. Thank you. Yeah. So
we have time for one more question here.
All right. So first of all,
thank you. Cruel intentions,
favorite movie of all time.
Um, so the best part of working at
Google is our colleagues are incredible.
And half of my meetings I'm like just
in awe at how talented the people are in
the room. So I was curious about
who you guys have worked with,
where you've had that moment of like,
oh my God, this person is so impressive.
Like who's the most impressive actor, uh,
that you've worked with outside of John,
obviously?
Well,
Gosh, I've worked with some really
amazing talented people, but the, yeah,
isn't it great that you can be
around people and you're like, wow.
And the great thing about movies
is it's a collaborative experience.
So every movie,
this movie has amazing,
we had so much fun and I
loved working on these people.
I'm trying to think of like one
person. I was like, oh my God,
this person is so incredible.
Maybe like super intimidated
when you found out they were,
oh, I ain't got to work with Jack
Nicholson once and I was pretty tight.
I can barely speak.
I mean,
it got to his clothes off and he was
standing there and I just kept inching and
just like, he goes, hey
kid, get out of my closeup
because I'm a leaner. I tie.
I tended to lean on people.
I like get away.
Um,
but I was struck about that.
That was pretty cool. Yeah,
that's, that's flooding John, to have you,
I guess on Snl till you've had a
lot of people come through it. Like,
have you experienced anything similar?
Um, well, I mean, obviously this movie,
getting to work with these
lanes and Nancy, um, at SNL,
right.
Specifically at Larry David
is my comedy hero. So,
uh, getting to work with him, it
was pretty awesome. I see the movie,
it comes out in theaters tomorrow,
September 8th.
Excellent question.
Yes,
Haley. Thank you guys. Wonderful.
God help you.